hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are gonna watch a top
rewards here request from Natalie Doran
who we met in person not long ago
Natalie very kind beautiful woman she
was very respectful to both John and I
mm-hmm
she hit on my girlfriend a lot you know
oh what's big titties you have I I was
hoping to hear those exact words like to
have a sunsets burger off your chim chim
chiminey buttocks
that's how Irish people talk chim chim
chiminey buddy yeah that that's Irish
slang all right in case you didn't
understand what that meant anyway we're
gonna watch BTS and I'm assuming some
Korean words Mike dropped
Steve ioki remix yeah this is what she
always requests and to you I say yes
[Music]
their sounds
to school
[Music]
oh cool
[Music]
whoa well you wanna microphones
Wow work this video I know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
Wow the Universal Studios lot yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're like oh yeah
[Music]
yeah I was heavy was having hardcore
they talked about growing up in Compton
mm-hmm they did resent what BTS can do
everything cocaine on the streets in New
York yeah I guess Steve I hokey on the
track oh he's cool
yeah his sister was in Sin City we're
gonna do a quick breakdown a little
loose cuz nobody knows BTS better than
Shawn and I write Curtis music video was
great
I loved how just this role and
in-your-face it was so let's just go
through the lyrics okay we all know they
make great bezoar videos but it's time
to break down the core of them mm-hmm
j-hope yeah who says my spoon is dirty
nobody I'm not saying your spoons dirty
I think you can clean up nice I don't
care when I grab the mic I have several
gold spoons I bet you do your part of
one of the richest people on the planet
several uncooked steaks over there make
me mad toss them on the grill buddy toss
them on the grill you just gotta heat it
up on man if it's uncooked cooker
yourself you might be rich but you don't
always need a serving once again I'll
chew you all up on the night of the
stars center of world business oh yeah
ain't going to exactly were that Mars
know exactly we happen there take
Dancing with the Stars at the Center for
world business and that's where he's
gonna go cuz they're gonna be on Dancing
with the Stars you nailed it Johnny now
let's see this is why you come to this
channel first on recruitment list
sold-out cuz you know eventually they're
gonna have to join the military that
happens the law in Korea the laws in
Korea the class is not common enjoyed
this value no you're above upper class
god oh no what the hell would call their
class a league of your own there's no
crying in kpop bad odors with good
scents are against the rules
ironic wouldn't you say are you talking
about like how Jon smells funky but
women gravitate towards him like he's
it's the funk
it's the fun it's the funk Mike Mike
bungee yes here's what I want to talk
about he says you thought was gonna fail
but I'm fine sorry so
a billboard sorry worldwide sorry mom
your sons too hot I've heard a few other
raps now he seemed to keep thinking that
people are doubting them yeah that
they're not gonna just keep breaking
records you don't have to apologize
anymore you're there you're there and
you're gonna continue to demolish
records so there's no need to say sorry
don't hey guys we know we know you're
gonna be consistently successful when
all the haters man there's so far below
you now yeah now look if someone's
willing to hate on you that means
they're already below you okay I'm being
a good son in place of you know cons in
our concerts I do it I do it you're bad
rata - I heard that they are huge Pixar
fans yeah most of the songs you can link
them back to the stories if you're
jealous
sue me sue it I have sued countless
people out of pure jealousy finally
someone in a rap song is talking about
it yeah so what's next oh did you see my
bag where did you see my bag but what's
in the bag it's hella trophies and it's
hella thick because they're constantly
winning she this is what I mean I am
what do you have to be sorry for whoever
doubts you is dumb maybe you just reach
a certain point of success where you're
on top of everything so you're just like
well let's just keep talking to the
haters anyway because now we have even
more stuff to rub in their face true
looks like Eminem in terrific transition
I bet it got my haters hella sick oh
look out come and follow me follow me
with your signs up Gemini I'm so firing
firing boy your time's up they're
talking about the movement hmm keep on
and running and running until I catch up
they are very good at their aerobics how
you dare how you dare how you dare I
don't know why I new I challenge a hair
person would never dare you another
trophy my hands carry them too many that
I can't even count them well if you're
carrying them they can't be that many
well there's seven of them so it's true
together I mean how many trophies can
y'all hold and one arm bundle like ten
good-sized ones I'll give you ten here
oh they got like 70 trophies probably
might drop mine an old might drop means
somebody stop me I'm about to pop off no
one's stopping you all do
hop it all the way guys are this storm
that is invading the world
hmm too busy you know my body ain't
enough turn it up now I don't think you
guys are busy enough honestly I've yet
to see you in Sherman Oaks California
yeah where is that show get on the
sidewalk hand out some mixtapes haters
gonna hate
players gonna play that's what I'm
always saying John that's how you greet
me every time I arrive here say hey
there's gonna hate and I'm a hater
so I'm hating no need to see each other
ever again this is my last goodbye no
more left to say don't even apologize
see you want a full circle you've met a
whole character art in this song look
closely look at your pathetic self oh
ouch why are you here I'm one of your
fans what the hell we shoot up just like
coca-cola with a Mentos in it
Oh took me a second I was like what your
corneas will be so shocked cuz we're
just so cool oh dude that's a mic drop
that is a mic drop no more going to
genius lyrics no more going to song
means org real rejects is your source
now for interpretation of Korean pop
yeah definitely definitely
although Korean pop I mean only yes not
black pink not txt no nothing is any of
us be to only BTS although while we are
on genius I just read that apparently
this song was inspired by Barack Obama
mm-hmm so you know you can totally see
that I mean this was actually a speech
that Obama gave during his second term
Obama I remember during his second term
it was actually around the time when
they found Osama bin Laden I remember he
was on the phone he said you're a bad
ratatouille
who says my spoon is dirty someone not
finished he stinks I think he might drop
after the Correspondents Dinner I think
that's the truly only Obama nugget in
here but just to know that BTS took note
of former President Obama as if that's
cool we still call president yeah yeah
that's not good enough for us anymore
just decipher how amazing their music
videos
just say their songs were good we want
to give you guys real additional content
and I think we've provided that you know
we got to do is we got to go through
frame by frame in this video pick out
all the symbolism pick out all the
hidden storylines
what are they doing in that room and
then that jail and then that other room
and what a steve aoki doing in the room
from the dark night this is why you got
to follow us at patreon.com slash tyrone
magnus definitely Natalie thank you so
much for requesting that's what can I
say
I mean after so long of knowing you
there our patreon page we finally got to
meet up with you in person and you are
just an absolute delight I wish we got
to hang out with you more it seems like
you had a good time in California sorry
for all the guys who kept honking their
horn at you that's on you that's your
fault you shouldn't dress the way you
dress or be a woman or yeah just
shouldn't look the way you look just
good like a parka and a bag and go
outside I blame you mm-hmm you're up
Nadia ratatouille with several gold
spoons a good setting protests oh no I
think we take all the wrong words from
BTS and apply them in two basic
sentences no definitely we shoot up like
coca-cola man oh yeah yeah I shoot up
yeah chase that dragon bud oh yeah John
does music video reactions on
patreon.com slash surreal reject
subscribe click that notification bell
and trust me all the content of the
music videos is just as good as our
deciphers was this video